if we could begin I'm built
I'm an editor at Yale University crest
I'm very proud to present our speaker
Christopher angry about the most
distinguished speaker on a secret
intelligence because possibly have he's
a professor of modern and contemporary
history at Cambridge former chair of the
history department there and chairman of
the Cambridge intelligence seminars he's
the Dean of a very recent field the
first academic journal of intelligence
intelligence in that patch of 30 was
founded only in 1985 co-edited by
Professor Andrew and Michael handle his
many books include histories of British
intelligence of US intelligence in the
presidency CIA several was on a TV and
an authorized history of the British
domestic intelligence service mi5
yesterday is absolutely fascinating
lectura was how to lead in secret
intelligence past from Asia to the West
today he'll speak on the strange history
of American British intelligence
relations from George Washington to
Donald J Trump the format is the same as
yesterday's professor Andrew will speak
for an hour and then we'll have half an
hour for questions please welcome
professor Christopher
[Applause]
well what I'm talking about my voice
William improve there's somebody who
gave me some wonderful third Lausanne
juices at the back and I know we'll be
able to provide some nor should they be
necessary which won't I say what I'm
about to talk about is I think just
about the the biggest gap until very
recently in the history not merely of
British American relations but also
international relations there we are two
powers they were both great powers that
at that point will pass over what has
happened to one of them since then who
had shared more secrets than any two
independent powers had ever shared
before and whose intelligence services
had cooperated in a way that
intelligence services had never
cooperated before so that's a subject
which is still somewhat new and which I
think there's a lot of worthwhile
material having worth having a look at
now why was it so difficult to research
well the key agreement which is this one
at the 1946 a Kucera greement idea I
know the man no longer around
Sir Harry Hensley who invented the term
Kucera those days it was brucer because
he said my boy he called everybody at my
boy whether or not they were boys or an
irrespective of gender so he said my boy
to me and he he said I knew the
Americans like acronyms so I thought I
did invent one but then just as I
arrived at Washington I thought oh hell
I've got him put the up before the osa
about two anyway so it Sarasota's ruined
so here is this key document I mean I'm
really finding very difficult to imagine
that anybody nowadays would even attempt
to write a history of the the Cold War
or for that matter
British American relations without
mentioning it but he even that was a
1946
it wasn't Declassified until 2010 so
what I'm talking about is only I think
being possible to write about in detail
comparatively recently so it ends up
with cooperation or perfect cooperation
which doesn't exist but nonetheless
unprecedented cooperation but it all of
course begins in conflict and it begins
in a conflict in which the United States
surpasses its main adversary with about
a spectacularly adds it's possible to
imagine George Washington the greatest
practitioner of intelligence certainly
in the first second half of the 18th
century and probably the whole of the
18th century but of course the irony is
that he learnt the techniques that he
used against the British against the
French first of all and then of course
the French became his his allies so what
he has to say
looks platitudinous now but the fact is
that planted he has only become
platitudes if they're true and people
did not say this beforehand finding
anyone who said something as obvious and
does truancies there is nothing more
necessary than good intelligence to
frustrate a designing enemy and nothing
that requires greater pains to obtain
and and then another extraordinary
statement which is one of course of the
many many treasures of the Sterling
library other places have reproductions
it's only the Sterling library in the
full-timer collection I knew well Terfel
so I'm pretty well and I remember
handling this document the necessity of
procuring god intelligence is apparent
and need not be further argued all that
remains for me to add is if you keep the
whole matter as secret as possible now
of course Washington wasn't perfect he
didn't have very much staff and he had
quite a number of agents so one has to
forgive him because he was fighting war
at the same time that he couldn't
remember their names
in a moment - one name that he could
remember so writing to one of his agents
it runs in my head that I was the
corresponding about fictitious name if
so I have forgotten the name and must be
reminded of it again it's possible I
think to be extremely sympathetic about
that dilemma so now we're back with you
I mean it's extraordinary isn't it that
it's pretty difficult thinking of any
American spy I was a single statue and
this man who died too early to actually
be a significant spire told us got five
there may be more than five but this is
the this is this is the the best-known
won't taken during the First World War
and this is an imitation at CIA
headquarters one of the budding
conspiracy theories that were generated
of course is that the CIA actually stole
the statue imitate it did then put it
back no they're not that good so it all
has a happy ending at least happy ending
this side of the Atlantic cool well
actually on the other side of the
Atlantic as well because really looking
after the United States is beyond
British capacity well it's beyond
British capacity then but it's
unimaginable now 1781 core Cornwallis
surrenders to Washington so this is a
spectacular intelligence victory as by
the way there are one or two seats at
the front end in in in other places and
it's it's a victory not simply for world
in the jargon is human to human
intelligence it's also victory for
code-breaking
and Washington knows it he personally
congratulate his crypt analyst James
Lowell on his success before and after
Yorktown so to continue a theme that I
was renting in late 16th century and
early seventies century code Briggs is
written in the United States got a
public recognition as I chances were
getting in the 20th and 21st century now
Louisville didn't get quite the same
level of recognition but that follows
the same theme so was he the best that
the president were the best grasp of
intelligence until
eisenhower well I can answer that
question perfectly straight forwardly
yes
now though one of the armed and to me
interesting things about the
intelligence history is that it is not
linear you cannot start from the
assumption that intelligence chief or
still more policymaking using
intelligence in the 20th century is
going to be better than in the 18th
century no intelligence to the handling
of intelligence is more likely to
degenerate over a period of hundred or
200 years than any other and there's a
very simple explanation for that it's
extremely difficult to learn from
experience but if you don't even know
what the experience was you have no
chance at all
so what happens nowadays is that how
because other examples later on is it's
extraordinary phenomenon of things that
they were regarded as totally new but
actually you know they were in some ways
more shocking 100 or 200 years back so
WikiLeaks now the only reason well I
don't think we need WikiLeaks but the
only reason that WikiLeaks found any
kind of role was that you can no longer
depend on the State Department to
publish all embarrassing dispatches sent
by ambassadors but of course um in the
second half there were little the last
generation from the 19th century you
could so have a look at this
the annual message of the President and
produced every year with the annual
report of the Secretary of State now
this is distributed in December at 9:00
to 1896 the documents go out to that but
it's printed in 1897 so it is no
exaggeration at all to say that u.s.
ambassadors beginning terrified about
what the State Department was going to
publish so there are just two examples
you could see he looks extremely
displeased George Perkins Marsh
ambassador to Italy for about 20 years
in his record he was just about to have
dinner there's a detailed description
with the Italian and for
Minister one evening when his valet
brought him up of the newspaper and it
had the headline was his denunciation of
Italian vacillation turd jubilation and
duplicitous and now now we move on to
Yale Eugene Schueller the first or the
equal first Yale PhD oh I see in 1961
that was even before that it was 1861 he
claims in 1886 ministers do not feel
free to express to the secretary of
state their real opinions for they
always have in view the possibility that
their dispatches may be published so
it's only because the statement problems
stopped wicked leaking that WikiLeaks
started wiki leaking instead the State
Department used to do far far better
right so now now I've delivered I could
have chosen all kinds of examples but we
are at the centenary of the First World
War and in a few days time it's going to
be the the centenary of the the
armistice now at the beginning of the
First World War the British leaders the
British M Prime Minister and the
American president have two things in
common they're probably the best
educated president and Prime Minister
certainly in the American case that ever
had I mean it's really not terribly
likely that the president of a major
university is in the foreseeable future
going to become president of the and of
the United States
Henry asketh or have a task with he
didn't like being called Herbert so he
called himself HH after a little while
he got a good Fleance class honors at
Oxford and a prize fellowship but paleo
so these people are extremely
intelligent understand politics and
political history very well and nowhere
near as good and I don't think I
exaggerate in the handling of
intelligence as their predecessors have
been in the 18th century so let's take
HHS quests and first his handling of
intelligence and their various examples
in my boat not in the same class as Pitt
the elder and
Pitt the Younger what does he use
intelligence for well as a way of
impressing his mistress Venetia Stanley
then in her mid-twenties he was in her
mid-60s as you can see from her
expression she wasn't all that impressed
really but there is in their
correspondence whose authenticity I do
not think has been challenged for one
moment the typical afternoon he wouldn't
write to her by the way at least once
every day sometimes three times a day
and sometimes in the middle of a cabinet
meeting then if he could get away he'd
like to have them think she quite liked
to have a nice ride in his coach and
they used to go down to row Hampton and
the south of London then he would show
her the latest intelligence and then he
would say I read it and she would say
yes and then I'm making none of this up
he would they were common papers as they
used to be cold he would get them he
would tell them into shreds make little
paper balls and flick them absolutely
and she was saying that they shouldn't
do that but of course he was trying to
impress her then here is a letter it
appears that the police because the
police came with a cardboard box which
had all these paper balls and unraveled
the police have discovered fragments of
top-secret papers they have reasonably
ously collected and the pieces came
around in a box this morning with a
severe admonition from Sir Edward grey
he was the foreign secretary at the time
as to the dangers to which the Foreign
Office cipher was exposed from such
loose handling of the secret matters and
what he says is that he was not guilty
but he goes on to say what damning
evidence you might have given well the
mere idea that Pitt the Younger OPP
elder would have behaved like that just
beyond imagination I know their views
within the United States now I'm just
being the most recent president doesn't
necessarily mean that you understand
more than let's say people two or three
hundred years ago that that is provably
true now in in the case of Woodrow
Wilson
not a figure of speech its I think you
know just very difficult to challenge
the evidence his grasp of intelligence
was much worse than Washington's and
indeed once the war had been safely won
he joked about how bad it was
so here he says after World War one let
me testify to this my fellow citizens I
not only did not know it until we got
into this war but I did not believe it
when I was told that it was true the
German he was not the only country that
maintained a secret service well no
tried telling that to George Washington
so but he did attach some importance I
have two secret correspondence
particularly with Colonel house his
foreign policy advisor to the the
quarter of Europe and he would only
allow three people had two and though
these ciphers which meant it was pretty
boring for him and his wife and Colonel
house to spend quote many hours of many
nights there decrypting not decrypting
the security cycles were decoding and
and encoding the happiest hours spent by
British codebreakers during the first
world one must exaggerate the happiest
minutes spent by British codebreakers
during the first world war but secretly
the correspondence of the President of
the United States who as you can see
from his expression is entirely unaware
of this although mrs. Wilson doesn't
look as if he has a suspicion that
something is important so they are it
never occurred to the British the
Wilsons of the British would do anything
like that and we are very sincerely
sorry
and so there's Samaras hanky the first
cabinet secretary which was not somebody
who makes the team it actually more or
less runs the country in the last 22
years he calls the u.s. decrypt in
valuable now for the first time there is
a brilliant and I use a brilliant advice
early by dr. Dan
Larsen's Cambridge PhD he comes from
Nebraska and lives extraordinary
combination of the two place the first I
mean the idea that after all these years
after the 70 volumes of Arthur link
alpha s link somebody can say something
these revolutionary new is pretty
extraordinary
now what is it why we able to get away
with it well Walter Hines page who's the
US ambassador in London is I'm happy to
say an Anglophile and an extraordinary
attempt to cultivate him is made by this
man who was the most influential
intelligent chief of first world war no
question he was director of Naval
Intelligence the trace of naval
intelligence aren't always the most
influential 30 years
he's called blinker because when he got
excited which is most of the time his
eyes blinked at page writes to Wilson
thank you it's pretty much sounds he's
fallen in love and he begins neither in
fiction or in fact can you find any such
man to match him well I defy anybody in
the room to find another dispatch for an
American ambassador that says that about
a Brit of any condition whatever and
then what he goes on at all the man is a
genius a clear case of genius all other
Secret Service men are amateurs by
comparison all can look for you and see
the very muscular movements of your
Mobile's own American diplomats don't
write like that anymore
and I don't blame them now what they
didn't realize of course though well Tim
Hall was getting a lot of fun out this
is the Admiralty old building it's where
it and it's still where it was you know
Whitehall and that's where room 40 where
the code-breaking where the set was
going on so he would stop by to have a
quick look at a broken American code and
then go on and be nice to Walter Hines
page so I mean there's a interesting
mixture of genuineness
and deception so what the Brits are
extremely delighted about is the fact
that the Germans play into their hands
how do they play into their hands by
really memorably incompetent sabotage
operations which begin to make you know
those that have been recently done by
the giu in Salisbury look moderately
competent so even a Wilson knows that
something is amiss I am sure the
country's honeycombed with German art
rege and infested with German spies the
evidences of these things are
multiplying every day that's on the
first anniversary of Britain entering
the First World War
so I mean you can tell from just a quick
look at this man that this is not the
kind of man that he would choose to be
put in charge of sabotage so the Front's
von papen becomes military attache in
Washington in July 1914 it's simply
amazing that he's not peeing heat until
December 1915 his career afterwards was
completely predictable that is to say he
becomes German Chancellor in 1932 and
Hitler's Vice Chancellor in 1933 to 1934
and you can see how much each admires
the other in in that photograph so the
biggest explosion in New York before
9/11 is this in 1916 in New York Harbor
that this is an episode that's so well
known the one I can't leave it out and
secondly I'm not going to say very much
about it the intellectually challenged
German Foreign Minister Alfred Zimmerman
thought that it would be a jolly good
idea if the Germany did get Walt in the
United States to get the Mexicans on
side and he believed that all he had to
do was offer them you know some of the
swing states in the midterm the midterm
elections the Foreign Secretary of the
Bava calls the moment when he hands the
decrypted telegram to page the most
dramatic in all my life now of course
didn't bring the United States into the
war but it helps to insure the weather
Stasia came into the war was indicted
nation and because nobody could say
anything very nice about the germans
after that and here is wilson telling
Congress that the telegram is eloquent
evidence that Germany quotes mean to
stir up enemies that their very doors
Lloyd George who understands these
things far better than Asquith but
hasn't learned elementary discretion he
becomes Prime Minister in December 1960
and he really likes Walter Hines page
and he likes the American ambassadors so
much that he tells him he really enjoys
reading his dispatches to Washington but
of course Walter Hines page is not
falling for that what's going on is that
the State Department is leaking the mid
watching because the Brits would no
never do anything like that now FDR is a
wonderful individual but you're very
good look at the faith he was a very
naive individual when he was a system
secretary for the for the Navy and
actually in charge of naval in
intelligence so no sooner had blinker
hall looked if FDR in the eyes that he
thought I think I got a fool him as well
and so he did when Roosevelt
subsequently decided he comes into the
Admiralty and blinking all blinking
furiously points to a twenty-something
that barely something-year-old of the
other side of the room and said I'd like
it what to ask boy where he was this
morning and so Roosevelt asks him and he
says silt sir and I'm being told where
silt was which is an island the German
Danish border Roosevelt was extremely
impressed
so brink of all explained that every
night a British spy would cross as a
border there and find this rather
unwholesome looking for a boat waiting
to bring them to Harrods nothing the
really remarkable thing is that this
made such a huge impression on Roosevelt
that at the beginning of the second
well war he repeats it to the then
director of Naval Intelligence Admiral
John Godfrey now I got for him
very rarely biddies tongue but he
realized him immediately what nonsense
he was but he also realized that FDR
still absolutely believed it and it
would help if he carried on believing it
blinker Hall had dicovered deployed some
fantastic cover FDR not only believed in
1918 but remembered to recounted his
words to halt success at twenty four
years later so there we are
everything's about to turn out right
there is Churchill who decides he
decides that the best thing to do we
can't possibly survive without the
American so why not just give them the
best intelligence we've got the ultra
intelligence make sure the President
sees this but meanwhile major parts of
British intelligence think that we can
need to carry on deceiving the United
States in order to form an alliance so
this is the exact words on 27th of
October 1941 that Navy and total defense
day that Roosevelt broadcast the
American people quote I have in my
possession a secret map made in Germany
by Hitler's government by planners of
the New World Order and it's this one
he goes on to say they have divided
South America into five vassal states
bringing the whole continent under their
domination this map my friends makes
clear the Nazi design not only against
South America but against the United
States as well well not quite because it
was a British forgery and this is men
who we do regret it very much this is
about the poor Teresa William Stephenson
little will Stephenson the head of
British security coordination which was
responsible for human not SIGINT liaison
in the United States and he got away
with it I mean the man who had lien for
an intelligence officer who had done
more to fool American intelligence than
anybody else in the entire history of
American intelligence as you say at the
end of the Second World War
there's Wild Bill Donovan
I'm pitting on his chest the u.s. middle
for merit which is the first
non-american to receive sorry and so now
things of course world history begins to
change it changes on the 7th of December
1941 talked about Pearl Harbor in
another context yesterday now
Churchill hears the news of Pearl Harbor
at checkers the country home of British
Prime Minister's we're Theresa May has
been up to some very odd things recently
and it so happens that that night
Roosevelt special envoy Averell Harriman
the u.s. Ambassador John violent are
there but they a chattering so whoops to
a good back one they are chattering so
much that even though the home services
used to be called rating for is is gonna
the the the news is on in the background
they just hear some vague reference to
Hawaii so they have to call in the
butler and the butler Sawyer says it is
quite true sir the Japanese have
attacked Pearl Harbor now it's I think
only in a British country house that the
news of world war can be delivered by
the butler I regret to say that this may
well be the last occasion which it
really happened now I mean the people
who really change things the
relationship between Churchill and
Eisenhower is just so extraordinary that
I don't think it's commonly realized
quite how extraordinary it was it's not
Roosevelt who persuades Eisenhower of
the importance of Ultra it's during his
first briefing with with Churchill then
Eisenhower did something which the best
of mine perfect knowledge no commander
in chief had ever done before he insists
that his G to his intelligence chief is
a foreign nationality so there we are
brief experience another one but this is
a man whose name is retained general as
he became a certain kind of strong
Kenneth's strong was brought up to a
British stiff upper lip they really
exist nowadays but he was an absolutely
prime example but when people started to
talk to him about the special
relationship after the Second World War
they noticed his upper lip quivering I
mean it was that that that extraordinary
but Eisenhower insisted on having him
when he became commander and Allied
commander in chief the war of his trying
to move him up he wasn't going to stand
for that so Kenneth strong remained now
I talked about Blakely yesterday but one
of the most extraordinary things to my
mind should there are people here who've
been into Fort Meade NSA headquarters
going down the corridor and seeing
notices which say you KL o United
Kingdom liaison office that is a pretty
extraordinary sensation and being at
Bletchley Park and seeing these people
there was against something well it
actually had happened before in world
history but it hadn't happened very much
but it's also the case that the other
biggest secret intelligence secret and
the other most successful intelligence
operation in which Britain is engaged
during the Second World War the double
cross system which I think most people
understand but is essentially not simply
by double agents but largely by double
agents persuading the Germans they were
getting extraordinarily good
intelligence whereas in fact it was only
made up by am pretty and also the United
States now the man who first of all I
mean OSS could could scarcely believe
that British intelligence was prepared
to take this but there were good reasons
from the point of view of British
intelligence so this is after all at a
time when 42 of the Yale class of 1943
joined OSS to a significant degree but
not wholly
the Yale story for even an ally to be
admitted to a full access to all secret
files and knowledge of their sources was
beyond precedent or expectation but the
British did it and no need to give one
feather back no man who agrees on the
American side is J Edgar Hoover and the
man who he puts in charge of cooperation
has an interesting subsequent career in
I think party to people though it
already but it's been relatively
recently revealed so here is Mark felt
um well-known from liking to pose with a
gun once which distinguishes him from
most of my former colleagues in mi5 look
what not pose quite like that
so he's the case office of her world war
two double agent peasant who is a Dutch
double agent who filled the Germans but
of course he has a really distinguished
career ahead of him so when Hoover who's
in position after all for longer than
any career in American history is have
been top of anything official after the
verdice he becomes number two and we now
know that he becomes something else as
well
he becomes arguably the most influential
whistleblower in US history he is deep
Frank as he admits in on in 2005 so as
an intelligence career going from the
double cross system so far as the
Germans are concerned to the double
cross system of the Nixon administration
not many comparisons that one can make
of their I'm the guy they called deep
throat now the main peacetime
consequence of well military
intelligence collaboration because it
depends on such a simple document hasn't
the best by imperfect knowledge got in
yet still got into a single biography of
Truman so what happens on the 12
September 1945 Truman who's seen in the
last months of the war
what's again collaboration can do
approves his continuation in peacetime
in a one-sentence memorandum the
Secretary of War and the secretary
hereby authorized to continued
collaboration in the field of
communication intelligence
Segen slide interview between the US
Army and Navy and the British and to
extend modify or discontinue this
collaboration as determined to be in the
best efforts of the United States this
has been available in the Truman
archives for 25 years I know I looked at
to verify but it's so this was a period
in when people were looking at great
power relations they didn't look at
sickened and of course that's the key
document which it leads to and which
I've already mentioned which remains
top-secret until 2010 but as soon as it
begins operating it changes a lot of
things and it changes history of
Cambridge University amongst other
things because in 1951 the UK USA code
breakers with actual Americans in the
lead identified this man the Soviet
agent codenamed Homer as a high-flying
British diplomat formerly stationed in
Washington Donald MacLean and there you
see in these slightly convoluted
language there's no there's no H in
Russian language so Homer becomes a coma
from the moment that MacLean has been
identified it is only a matter of time
but actually quite some time before
filled in the others identified as well
but that's how it begins but we there is
a tendency I detected myself as well to
take so much for granted Intel is
collaboration between Britain and the
United States and some of the most
critical amendments of the of the Cold
War that it's worth I think remembering
just how an extraordinary it was at a
personal level not simply a Segen so
here we are the most dangerous moment
probably in the history of the world
Cuban Missile Crisis the only crisis
which could well have ended in
thermonuclear warfare and that's one of
the initial photographs we
Shem shows a Soviet missile base under
construction but unless there was an
agent who was providing plans for the
construction of Soviet missile bases you
couldn't tell how close they were to
being operational but you could because
it was one and he was this man and they
the way that he was jointly run by
Britain and the United States I think is
actually unique in British American
relations so there is recruited by the
the Brits run jointly with the CIA until
there's a missile crisis and when he's
it means interrogated in London where
he's managed to get as senior member of
a delegation and there're them there are
the four people two Brits to Americans
who interrogate him and the the leading
Brit Harry Shergold
whose control of Soviet bloc has used to
be called in Esaias he's the one looking
at him now again I I have not come
across a photograph remotely like this
what on that evening
Penkovsky has asked the Brits and the
Americans the CIA and sis to do he is a
soviet colonel well he explains his real
loyalty is to London and Washington so
he insists on being able to dress up as
a u.s. colonel on the left and a British
Colonel on the on the right as an
episode in intelligence collaboration
and well and the second greatest Western
agent - I have a great good fortune of
knowing extremely well then when I was
working with him there was a lot that we
couldn't say that Ben McIntyre's
excellent recent book is able to say so
there he is
the Brits can't believe their luck he'd
been working for sis since 1976 1974 a
big apartment but then he's posted to
London in 1982 and this is an mi5
surveillance photograph is the the mi5
team that takes the photo and the
slightest idea that
the fact Britain's most important agents
and not working for the Russians at all
so what do we get out of him there's
this combination of strategic and
operational material which is is quite
extraordinary this is and this is one of
the documents that he brought out
initially on both sides of granting
people couldn't really believe but
they'd always underestimated the role of
conspiracy theory in determining Soviet
intelligence objectives so here we are
the belief that Reagan is planning a
nuclear first strike I've gone over the
most recent evidence in my book and that
qualifies as a strategic intelligence
document of the highest importance but
what it goes along with is a better
insight than ever been provided before
into the operational my new CI and you
can't have an operation unless you have
operational my new CI so where was the
KGB's favorite dead letterbox in London
well I had more than one but they liked
Catholic churches dozen of them quite
attractive and they'll tend to be du mal
it than Anglican churches so most of
this is it tells agents who are new to
London how to find the Brompton Oratory
which is the biggest Catholic Church not
not the yep not the biggest Catholic
place of birth which is because of
Westminster Cathedral Westminster Abbey
so the typist is allowed to type most of
it but then if you you go four lines
down you see it says Harod now how did
is of course Harrods because KGB
illegals were great shoppers and they
they knew that they could find their way
to to Harrods so the standard
instructions would be first go to
Harrods and then there's some further
instructions including the Victoria and
Albert Museum
so anyway by night all day finding
Harrods was was not difficult and the
dead letter box which you find because
we publish these these documents
is just to the left you can see one of
the side altars there's the Pieta copy
of Michael enters celebrated statue in
in Rome then at the the same level as
the inscription which you can't see
consul Martinez it is finished Christ
last words from the cross just behind
that pillar which is partly set into the
wall there there's the dead letter box
where messages were well have been
recovered I recalled that this is 20
years ago it's been doing an article
with their like in the Sunday Times and
we we gave them this is a picture which
I would like to say was taken by my
daughter after Oleg gave over the the
the details and somebody from The Sunday
Times it was naive enough to think that
if he sat there all day somebody would
come either deposit a secret document or
collect well they never did so as a man
admitted he don't really fell out and
went into the confession box and instead
of saying forgive me Father for I have
sinned
he said forgive me father you realize
you've been giving confession next to
okay to be dead letter officer last 20
years and it turned out that he didn't
so where are we
yes and then also standard stuff but the
way of indicating you've left something
can Brompton Oratory is straightforward
you find the correct Ballabh this one
was codenamed Quran you put a bit of
chalk on it you collect your stuff and
then you rub out the that there the
chocolate from the moment that you know
this is how operating in London it
becomes strategically much simpler to
follow what they're doing and here is
Oleg after his unique escape from Moscow
being congratulated by Ronald Reagan I
think the first time that American
president has publicly congratulated one
of the leading agents of an allied Tim
power right now it looks an awful lot
different now doesn't it well why our
code is gonna be not that different
from what used to be going on so anyway
our this is Edward Snowden I can't allow
the US government to destroy privacy and
basic liberties and there is again thank
you Edward Snowden and to both the
Guardian and The Washington Post win
Pulitzer Prizes but are the best of my
knowledge not a single of the huge
number of articles online articles in
print and talk about the impact that
Snowden's revelations had realized that
they weren't remotely on the scale of
what had happened in the early Victorian
period I'm about to reveal those what's
this consequence of well it's a
consequence I'll forgive me I don't
invent many acronyms but this is what
I'm sticking with historical attention
span deficit disorder has anyway that's
fine and so what happens Snowden easy
it's Matt Cellini maxine he was past his
best
supposing he'd ever had a best but he
was he was an italian latch to his
revolutionary not nice man but not
pretty very good at being either a
nationalist or a revolutionary and he
came to london he had a really nice time
but he started complaining that his
letters were being opened now the whole
of the media and also a huge majority in
parliament was so outraged by Mancini's
letters being opened that they force the
closing down of britain's SIGINT agency
this is thomas carlyle practice near of
kin to picking men's pockets and so so
it's all closed it's all closed down and
the effect of snowden it could be argued
in in britain as in the united states
has been ultimen the extent that
governments have been forced to be
straighter about what they do and put
some justification for it but the
suggestion that snowden comes anywhere
close to having the the effect that
Matt Xenia when he made his complaints
is absurd so what do you get you get
this extraordinary moment they fall the
first threat of war the two leading
French diplomats at the time poor combo
Yugi combo
Paul for better part of 20 years French
ambassador in London Jude Kanban for
rather lesser time French ambassador in
in Berlin they have a correspondence
between each other but obviously they
don't use the French diplomatic bag
because the Cato sayin opens interesting
letters so they correspond by the only
method they know to be completely beyond
suspicion that is to say the British
diplomatic bag how times have changed so
there is a good consequence to all this
because the Brits are forced to
improvise at the beginning of the First
World War
they've got knock off an established
SIGINT agency so they get some people
who are so eccentric that nobody has to
my knowledge recruited such people
before so here is the King's College
Cambridge classicists dilly dilly Knox
now he breaks some codes it's a really
very sensible way which had never been
done before to the best of my knowledge
in an official organization he's in room
40 but when faced with a difficult
cypher and by the way the evidence for
this is beyond them a dispute he retires
to room 53 because that's where the
parties and one of the things I worry
for about students nowadays I don't know
Richard were at Yale but in the old days
I mean we used to tell our students who
were looking at a blank sheet of paper
and not able to write something or a
blank screen now stuff all that go and
have a good bath and relax yourself and
you'll write something really
interesting giving them showers how am I
supposed to think with all that water
pounding I looked over their heads
I've been very uninfluential I regret to
say and trying to book that right so the
sailor in room 53 years never it's true
been to sea but they're not in a boat he
has yet sort of float in a bath in the
Admiralty they do it's not very good
point but that's the best they could do
at that period now well the greatest
discoveries
in British intelligence archaeology is
only three years ago Bletchley Park
found the very bath on the left-hand
side there is John Scarlett it was
former head of chief of mi6 sis and
there was a royal person in the middle
and now the Duke of Kent doesn't do a
lot but he normally presents the prizes
at Wimbledon what look it is his
expression and makes you realise that
he's not quite clear what's and what's
going on but once the Americans had been
introduced to Dilli Knox they took a
real interest in Hammond cheering an
extraordinary individual who's been a
tense to fashionable cause is perfectly
reasonably but he was a bit Asperger's
amongst many other things but when he
sent over to the United States
forgetting his identity documents in
November in 1942 and he stays until
March 1943 that is a turning point in
British American intelligence
collaboration now his papers are in
King's College Cambridge this is done by
his his mother and shows its individual
approach to the towards life I mean the
standard entry tests for Yale and
British intelligence will probably
exclude somebody who behaved like this
in a hockey match so as you see other
people are playing a really fierce and
game of field hockey but Allen's
attention has been seized by a group of
daisies and then a sample wholesome
story at the beginning of the second
world war when he moves to Bletchley
Park he transfers his life savings into
silver ingots he realizes paper money is
going to depreciate during the-- the
world you got by Goulding and so silver
infants and he buries his life savings
and silver ingots in the black awards
and he was a tragic figure at weekends
after the Second World War as he went
around Bletchley Woods trying to work
out what the hell it put them
well I predict that star in the King's
College fundraising magazine and
delighted to say that there was somebody
who had actually been with him while he
was doing that so there is cooperation
for the story now if this is the very
last point that I'm about to make and
the United States says I don't think
that's me that it might be my place
makers sometimes does all things so
intelligence is the only profession in
which a fictional character is many
times better known than any real
professional alive or dead and you see
the individual that I have in mind but
this is due to American as well as
British influence it's difficult now to
remember that Ian Fleming was thinking
of giving up bond but when John F
Kennedy is or his advisors are asked to
name his ten favorite books he mentions
From Russia With Love and so a bond
success in the United States it's that
which persuades Ian Fleming to continue
the novels and it's it give us one I
mean talk about toning and cheek I mean
this is rather deplorable really so bond
is given in several of the film's a CIA
ally Felix Leiter God knows why he's
looking through cheerful because bond of
course emerges unscathed for everything
whereas Felix Leiter comes fairly close
to a luminous ex-serviceman although he
does have one arm and one leg left at
the left at the end and then then of
course only I think Buckingham Palace
could have last time I gave the example
of the way the Queen Elizabeth the first
favorite final frock celebrated the
successes of British intelligence now
the way that Her Majesty Queen Elizabeth
the second used the opening of the
ceremony of the Olympic Games where the
most optimistic moment in British
history over the last decade and not
going to arrive a
the the mood now so what happens she
summons bond there he is in Buckingham
Palace god bless her at the age of 87
she's about to do with her first
parachute jump and who's she going to do
it with him now I know that there are
people that say that he was a body
double but ladies and gentlemen that's
what Republicans say in person they
refuse to accept that their majesty did
it and they're not necessarily wrong but
it's deeply unpatriotic there we are
you can tell it's her first parachute
jump she hadn't got a lot of English
experience but it all ends happily so
there's the Royal Box now I'm going to
reveal a source which has never
previously been revealed in university
immediately behind her you can see there
there is a gent with a snowy beard and
the certain amount of hair who's
clapping as well
he is the outer Bishop of Canterbury
he's now after having done that an
impossible job absolutely brilliant for
10 years he's been given a compassionate
leave and it's now a master of one of
the colleges at Cambridge University
mortal in modelling college the Queen
liked him very much but I mean if you
compare his haircut which actually was
less respectable than it normally was
she said to a wandering bishop who
wandered through Corpus Christi College
I can't mention who he was there was the
Bishop of Ely and she she said the
bishop he knew and that she was gracious
and pleased to be graciously pleased
with Rowan Williams but her Majesty
added I do sometimes wonder if I should
lend him a comb but no he never did
he's completely unspoiled but what he
tells me is that Her Majesty's parachute
jump was unknown to the whole of the
royal family including her husband who
looks a bit bemused and so there we are
Oh only Britain I think with rigid
help from John F Kennedy has been quite
as creative in the some fictional image
but this is an important part of real
intelligence because the majority of the
world's population have seen Bond films
you know increasingly of 35,000 feet
rather than that at ground level and
they nearly always enjoy them so it
means that when we recruit people from
other countries they're more likely to
say yes to a British request than to a
number of other countries that come to
mind right no it's just time to end as
synthesis in the midterms with
continuity and change what the over the
last year we've seen two things that
have never happened and never come close
to happening in US intelligence which
affect the special relationship than the
first days all those years and I talked
about this last last time
all those years after Stella Remington
in 1992 became the first female head of
any of the world's major intelligence
agencies under the trump presidency of
all presidencies the first female CIA
director at Gina Haspel is is promoted
and then you know again something that
has not happened in any major
intelligence service that I could think
of the denunciation mutual denunciation
between the the president and former
intelligence chiefs and all that within
it well the calling people bad persons
went on for quite some time beforehand
but so at one at the same time we're in
a situation so far as British American
intelligence relations are concerned
which can only be explained in the
extreme long term but we're also seeing
short term deviations which were
unimaginable even a few years ago thank
you
[Applause]
Russia next time by the way in that case
you've already given professor Andrew
yes I mean my understanding which I'm
happy to have amended a nuance by
anybody here that it's extremely good
and the the problem for any intelligence
agency is that they need to have people
with whom they can test their
conclusions so the United States is not
about to find other intelligence
agencies which can do this is absolutely
central I mean any scholar for example
most of the people in this room unable
to test their conclusions on fellow
scholars they're suffering from a real
handicap intelligence agencies and
intelligence analysts have less
opportunity to do that than any other
profession
I don't know that he wants the the best
pie but he was sadly the best
codebreaker I mean there were not many
people and trying their hand to me fits
a number of the criteria one he's a very
good mathematician and secondly he has
the the ear of Washington as we can tell
from the correspondence
[Music]
well I think I'm putting the second
point that you made as to what the
president tweets at 5:00 a.m. in the
morning it's a source which is
unfortunate beyond me and I do have
difficulty in in interpreting what of of
course is the case is that necessarily a
lot of signal Persians combined
operations so for example we had Hong
Kong and the Americans did not so a lot
of the operations were run and by the
way one of the the documents that
Gordievsky and i published in was it
instructions in the center or more
instructions the center is the KGB's
take on american british collaboration
there and it's because you have this
extraordinary phenomenon of not an
allied intelligence service that are
fully integrated one in both Cheltenham
and and and and for Fort Meade it's very
difficult sometimes to carve off not
difficult in some parts of the world but
where there is an agreed target which is
approached from a number of different
directions and Libya under Gaddafi
there's pretty good example of that so
as I think I had to he explained the
reason that he could have been yesterday
which seems a long time ago but yes I
think it was yesterday the reason that
Reagan becomes the first American
president to visit NSA headquarters at
Fort Meade is that you had to go along
to apologize for having quoted some of
Gaddafi's intercepts after the Lebel
discotheque bombing in in in Berlin but
of course some of the stuff that he was
quoting was actually British
SIGINT so I would really start from the
fact that because the the American
operation was far far bigger
the British could ever be but because
they're fully integrated the idea that
against major targets you can completely
separate one out from the others I think
it's a difficult concept too difficult
for me anyway I would think I will have
to remind some people who Anthony K
Brown was he was I mean he was the first
person to reveal ultra in the the early
1970s he was also a traditional British
bounder you know the kind of person who
would get expelled from his London club
but who would not behaved disgracefully
at a level beyond that and I am I
remember who the same generation you
will recall that there was a man called
Fred Winterbottom and Fred Winterbottom
who had some background in what I mean
intelligence wrote really the the first
firsthand book explaining how it was
done and he kept going along to the
we're now back to Anthony tape around
kept going along to Winterbottom's home
but what he wished to do was contact
private research and his archives while
Kay brown while Winterbotham was was
away so all I can tell you what
Winterbottom told me and broadly
speaking if he was truthful he was
returning with his wife from divine
service one Sunday when he noticed the
ample form of an to decay Brown stuck in
the scullery window
absolutely took another I mean he was a
proper bounder and you don't get that
kind of thing now that is it just so
nasty antisocial people a lot of
traditional villains sorry you know I
mean it's it was almost immediately it's
simply that it was mainly an American
British agreement and then the others
were added on but it's an example of let
me give a Canadian example of just how
close the relationship is GCHQ is
publishing next year it's official
history it's going to be pretty limited
in what it says about interception and
decryption methods for the Cold War but
nonetheless it will be well done and it
will be a real advance and who have they
chosen to do it
a Canadian historian and this is you
know the most secret activity in which
Canada REM engages and for one of their
people to be living in to the British
end it's as with all special
relationships whether they are
friendships between individuals or
collaboration between organizations the
thing that takes years to to build up is
that kind of confidence but throughout
the five eyes you can find those
extraordinary kinds of relationship
which it's almost impossible to
replicate outside them once you know
once you I mean the the simplest way I'm
not going to attempt it but from if I
were to to ask all those here who you
share most personal secrets with you to
give me a checklist of your closest
friends and the same is true at an
international level in the organisation
particularly in the intelligence
organization the people whom is closest
other peope
with whom it says more secrets than any
other yes yes yes well because it was
necessary to have a scapegoat I mean
there were stuff that did require
somebody to fall on their the salt and
the Bay of Pigs is of course the example
but it's interesting least to me but
when Kennedy sacked him he said is this
with the United Kingdom I would be
resigning but this is the United States
and you're resigning yes
I think initially it was not Tim so much
won't feel be revealed as it's the the
the the the breach of trust and that the
same is true after all of individuals if
you have your a really good friend over
a period of years and then you can no
longer trust them that's not something
which those individuals who suffer and I
think always completely recover from and
the the the case that I have in mind in
the American case is filled with just
about America and best American friend
was James Angleton who for some reason
is nowadays called James Jesus ankles
and I don't believe till his lifetime we
use the the middle initial very very
much
but I don't think angleton ever
recovered and the people in this room
the bread sauce the literature he became
a conspiracy theorist and that that was
the damage that was done once Trust is
is completely breached putting it back
together at least with the main
individuals concerned is very very
difficult
well the this is this is a real
conundrum first them some of the the
evidence Gordievsky had been in the
immediate aftermath of his success
during Gorbachev's first visit to
Britain he was the heir apparent and
Chernenko have been terminally ill for
as long as anybody could remember was
not yet certified debt and it's
perfectly clear that Ghana shelf was
going to take over so he did a terrific
job and he was really good at briefing
Margaret Thatcher although he did that
through written and briefing gavotte off
at the at the same time so at that at
that point he's appointed as the
resident designate and then he's also
allowed to go back you obviously know
a good deal of this Pacific is probably
essential contact for anyone who doesn't
he's invited back to Russia and as he
said to me you know I just felt there
was something wrong about it but I told
myself you know you're nervous beginning
to crack so he he went now the
difficulty is the following one that
Ames did betray a Philby and he's lied
about when he behaved he betrayed filthy
but it looks as if it was April 1985 and
by that time Philly Gordievsky has
already been portrayed now and I have a
theory which I'll pass on which I don't
attach huge importance to but which
nonetheless might turn out to be right
when Gordievsky they finally gave him
such things as truth drugs but anyway
when they put the stuff in the Armenian
brandy and he found himself talking
umpteenth to the Dozen when it was all
over the man who would have been
interrogating he said you know you will
never guess the way that we discovered
what you're what you've been up to now
even the slightest thought that gaudy
ASCII whatever escaped because no
intelligence officer not simply
intelligence officers from the Soviet
Union while they were under KGB
surveillance had never got away before
so my feeling is that is actually as
very frequently happens in discoveries
of all kinds of combination of a bit
here and a bit there one of the crucial
things that he's probably that the
senior deputy at the time when in the
London residency the senior deputy at
the time when Gordievsky is given the
job is the head of the Caroline
counterespionage and it seems to me
quite likely the what he was attempting
to do was build up a case
to damage Goulding ev Sookie so just to
summarize the Amos explanation doesn't
do it because I think the timing doesn't
quite work since the the man who told
Gordievsky that it was extremely
complicated never work it out no just
assumed that he'd be executed
this would never be used to mislead the
West I think that formula is the is the
right one so I think a variety of
material was put together and the
mailing was critical in doing it was a
head of the kettle on
[Applause]
you
[Music]